und dann Treppe ich das einfach so small
ja genau also eigentlich der Pipette
zwei Tropfen direkt auf Zunge
im Winter dunkler wird ist alles in
beliebte Mutter machen es wirkt
tatsächlich aber es kommt gesetzten
[Musik]
versuchen und was Schatten sind vor dem
microdocing Trend
drum schalte ich meine Reportage da wo
ich mich Minecraft
[Musik]
vielen Leuten hilft zum Arbeiten eben
viel Motivation etc also ich weiß
einfach so vom LSD und so mit wie mega
Gesellschaft
ja spitze mir als Microsoft endlich dann
reden
halt nur halt ein bisschen also viel
sanfter eben dass man halt schon noch
klar kommt eben und dass man ja was hat
gemacht das hat mich das hat dann
einfach ein bisschen vitaler gemacht ein
bisschen spiritueller ein bisschen
kreativer einfach durch den Tag gebracht
man hatte ich hatte viel Energie können
alles erledigen noch drumherum wir waren
Basketball spielen
auf jeden Fall leicht verstörend würde
ich sagen
kommt
relativ jung gewesen
das vorstellen
keine Ahnung was ist man hört
Sensibilisierung der Gefühle würde ich
sagen Emotionen der
Wahrnehmung etc alles für alles geht in
einem ein so alles so alles geht
ineinander und fahren mit den Farben
intensiver Gerüche etc
irgendwie
ist wirklich relativ bekannti Praxis
so eigentlich nicht erwartet ja
[Musik]
LSD oder andere psychedelische
Substanzen für ihre halluzino-effekt
bekannt sind nehmen wir aber eben nur
eine mikrodosis von 5 bis 20 Mikrogramm
LSD zu sich also richtig dosiert denn er
wäre bereit
die wahrnehmigt
Kreativität steigere der Fokus
schärfamilie Energie in Alltag bringen
fröhlicher und offener mache konsumiert
werden meisten
Alkohol aufgelöst sind und im Internet
finden immer 100 die vorarbeitige und
Videos zu Dosierung und zum Satz
verkauft wird LSD unter der Hand und wir
zahlreiche andere Substanzen vor allem
am Darknet über Social Media snapchat
oder wir verschlüsselte telegram Kanal
zahlt wird in Bitcoin wir QR Code oder
Apple Geschenkkarte wo es euren kioskit
alles anonym und superzwilling
nur im Ausgangsthema sondern einem
Alltag Überträger bin ich mit der Reha
in Kontakt
Psychologie da in Zürich und hat
Microsoft Uni und beim Studieren
angewendet aktuell
[Musik]
wie verbreitet ich schon das überhaupt
so unterstudierende
quasi LSD ausprobieren
im Studium
sehr tabuisiert ist und
wir sagen sehr Schlachten
Bibliothek wo du quasi gemerkt dass es
wirkt jetzt also wirklich
nur Microsoft gemacht haben also
wirklich sehr niedrige Dosis ist dann
merkst du eigentlich kein Anfang kein
Endpunkt also ich kann das nicht gemerkt
und darum ist sie einfach
sexistischer Vergangenheit das heißt
wirklich dass sie aber wirklich gemerkt
Hannes nicht aktiv
der hauptknovern und dann eher
rückblickend
zurückblicken dann reflektiert und da
gemerkt wie es sich ausgewirkt hat und
bin zulosen
aber ich mag mich jetzt nur so genau an
den Tag erinnern wo vier Jahre
zurückliegt das heißt irgend später
passieren
irgendetwas Positives erinnerige und der
ganze Tag kann ich glaube mit der
Lockerheit gemeistert wo sonst so ohne
Tag auch vielleicht mit dem Motivation
oder so verbunden sind aber der Tag ist
irgendwas
gegangen und einfach so und früheren Tag
sind eigentlich
relativ praktische Mittel weil es gibt
aber trotzdem habe ich jetzt nicht das
Bedürfnis für spürt dass immer wieder zu
benutzen also es ist halt doch
illegale Superstars und
ja also
wird aber nicht nur als Hirndoping dem
Lernen oder als leistungsmittel im
Ausgang benutzt sondern auch zur
Entspannung wenn ich jetzt unterwegs
Lockdown zur Entspannung ausprobiert
aber nicht gemacht
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
wahnsinnig gut gegangen
hat es sehr wahrscheinlich konsumiert
die ganze Nacht und entsprechend
sicheren entscheidende Punkt ist
bei ihrem Versuche entspannungssuche
[Musik]
und zu dem Zeitpunkt im Reportagen ich
fühle mich Überfahren von dem Thema im
Internet nur so vor Videos zu microsing
und langsam beschließt mich das Gefühl
dass der ganze Micro daising Trend vor
allem auch ein Riese Miete Hype
das bestätigen
Reportage nicht einfach nur ein weiterer
random Betrag von Michael Rosen
geschaffen auf der anderen Seite zeigt
mir das Neugier zum Thema riesig ist
veröffentlicht kann aber offenbar das
erste Mal nach einer Wiese das microsing
tatsächlich ein positive Effekt hat
drum mache ich mich mit auf den Weg der
Amazon
über 100 Patientinnen und Patienten mit
LSD therapiert die Psychotherapie wurde
LSD unterstützt wird statt grundsätzlich
allen
interessant die Studie zeigt dass auch
mikrodose nicht der erste
Doppelblindstudie wo das zeigt das
mikrodose
dass sie das
tierdosis mit der resubstanz wirklich
zum Medikament habe werde zum Beispiel
wie Depressionen weil dort das ist das
größte Interesse trotzdem die Probanden
gefühlvollen Energie wohlbefinde
Kreativität Glück
Verbundenheitsgefühl hat dosierten Tag
wir stehen
wenn sie gerade denke dass es die kleine
Dose von Alkohol auch hervorrufen und
die wirklich den verschwindet an deine
Decke wo man keine Alkohol trinkt
halbes biertes oder defekt
sogenannte orthopädische Effekt auf
psychische
Therapie
wo irgendwie verkrampft sie ist wo
blockiert sie ist und in der Volk sind
dann wieder andere Bewegung möglich
andere denkt bewege in dem Sinn unter
Standardbedingungen können noch müssen
Regionen von hier mit anderer
kommunizieren oder LSD und psybin ich
vieles möglich was übrig ist und das
öffnet halt die Türe zu neuem wenn sich
gesunde Menschen mit LSD mich selbst
optimiere wird es so theoretisch am
effizientestenose funktioniert dass der
für die Schweiz aktuell Nummer psychisch
Kranke
Patienten können aussuchen entweder im
Bett
ihre Erfahrung haben auf meine Sessel
das ist relativ selten meistens sitzt
ein Arzt oder
schlechtere Pfleger und die andere
Möglichkeit ist direkt am Boden
Moment bitte eine Patientin und
Patienten
genau
wir wissen wie viele Patienten
Psychotherapie irgendwann einmal
psychische Spuren in der Umsatz holen
und eine
Landschaft die psychischen Landschaft
wieder zu öffnen das irgendwo anders
auch wieder eine
so Alternative
alternative Denkmuster alternative
Verhaltensmuster wieder keine zu
entwickeln wie man sich seinen
grip-momen muss vorstellen weißte Felix
schalkmann einer der therapeutische
Effekt als gesunde Proband im Rahmen von
einer Studie von der Uni Basel erlebt
und Dad ein rund 20 bis 30 Fach so
[Musik]
höheren
Felix
Physiker
forscht weil der hohen Dosis von 200
Mikrogramm LSD
habe ich dann
zusehends den den Bezug zu meinem Körper
verloren
bin eigentlich dahin gedriftet wenn man
so will und dann war ich woanders ich
habe auf einmal
mich erlebt als Fötus
in der Plazenta und das verrückte war es
hat sich so real angefühlt ich war
wirklich in diesem Zustand drin ich war
der Fötus ich habe schauen können und
sah das Gewebe
von der plazent oder ist das rötlich
dunkle Gewebe diese Umgebung und habe
gespürt wie in was für einem Zustand ich
bin und der Zustand war leider nicht
angenehm irgendwas lebensbedrohliches
passierte und wurde so stark dass ich
dann das Gefühl hatte ich schaffe es
nicht mehr das ist so lebensbedrohlich
ich kann so nicht mehr weitermachen und
in dem Moment habe ich
interessanterweise rechts eine eine
weißes Licht gesehen und ich habe das
Gefühl gehabt jetzt muss ich entscheiden
ob ich als Fötus weiter kämpf gegen den
Zustand oder ob ich loslasse
das sind auch Zustände die die von NATO
fahrenden berichtet wurden und da ist es
auch schon ganz gut belegt dass diese
Erfahrungen unglaublich profund sind
aber andererseits natürlich auch das
Potenzial haben das Leben zu
destabilisieren weil man danach sich
selbst und die Welt anders sieht
und das auch in der Regel irreversibel
also man hat einmal hinter den Vorhang
geschaut und
das was von da gesehen hat dass das wird
man nicht mehr los und in der Regel war
das aber so
unglaublich und und und
überwältigend dass es ein positiven
Eindruck hat gleichzeitig ist es dann
nicht ganz so einfach wieder in der
normalen Welt
mit dem Alltag zurecht zu kommen
oder 20 bis 30 Fach so erhöhe ich das
schwierig wie man bei Minecraft
auf keinen Fall unterschätze richtig
dosiert sind aber Gefahr von der
Überdosis bei
microsingli grundsätzlich ist
bekannt wie zum Beispiel wie Heroin
körperliche Risiko also überschaubar
trotzdem waren z.B blau sucht Schweiz
hingeht frag ich direkt bei der
Fachstelle
wie gefährlich ist denn Microsoft aus
ihrer Sicht
also
körperlich nicht abhängig macht Risiko
liegt ganz klar im psychischen Bereich
also wäre tripperlebt da hat das auch
sehr belastenden Finger das hat so
Orientierungslosigkeit
zu Panikattacken also
Dosis wo Gott sei Dank gebrochen
körperlich weiß man eigentlich an LSD
nicht abhängig machen
funktionale Abhängigkeiten die also dann
sehen dass die konsumieren
danke danke
ob das wirklich zu der psychischen
Abhängigkeit führt ist und klar
zum Teil auch für so Selbsttherapie zum
Beispiel bei depressive Verstimmung im
Winter oder auch zum Teil Angstzustand
und was muss man denn da liegen probiert
dann fallen mir sehr Vorgänger
bestehende psychische kranke negativlos
oder geht mir sicher große Risiken wenn
man so zum zusammen
Therapien und
wie dem Grund wieso es die meisten
überhaupt einsetzen bitte stimmig die
Psyche wenn man also versucht ein fair
Stimmung sauber und ohne Begleitung von
Fachpersonen mit LSDs therapieren
und dann passiert nach dem Gespräch mit
Zucht Schweiz das was ich fast nur für
Möglichkeiten haben im Raum
[Musik]
genau das sie therapiert sich aktuell
gerade mit LSD sauber Michael Dost jetzt
schon der zweite Winter und nochmal kurz
Telefon ist ja auch bereit mir vor der
Kamera rauskommt
[Musik]
wunderbar
so will ich eigentlich so als Mensch
relativ viel Licht brauche und dass ihr
euch im anderen mangelwaren
ja es ist schon schön
ich liebe gefühlt
also Flüssigkeit
und das ist einfach mit Therapie bitte
und von dem nehme ich jetzt jedes Mal
zwei Tropfen angefangen und mit zwei und
dann
ja genau also eigentlich der Pipette
und dann Gottes ist momentan
bis ich das ein bisschen entfalte
und es wirkt also das wo du dir erhofft
hast
also tatsachlich eigentlich wir mit der
Milch
überhaupt
das Down wie verstärkt wird ja aber
extrem also dass man irgendwie mega Loch
geht oder so in der also was auf jeden
Fall nie passiert ist das dass wir reden
wie funktionieren dass man es nicht so
gut geht das ist dann nicht so aus
erholt also ich glaube dann immer noch
mega viel Strom
nicht dass das eigentlich sowieso ein
Notausgang als Notausgang wird die
funktionieren
Abhängigkeit redet man weiß ja
körperlich macht es nicht abhängig LSD
es geht ja kein tödliche Dosis aber die
funktionelle Abhängigkeit quasi dass man
halt wie Wohlbefinden Glück Kreativität
aufsprüfstoß oder auf tropfen kann von
dem abhängig werden
ich glaube mir sind sogar alle abhängig
nach Glück und Wohlbefinden und
ich denke aber es ist sehr individuell
was man Suchtverhalten hat überhaupt
nicht generell sagen und eben ich kann
Pause gemacht und es ist überhaupt kein
Problem
und
ja ich glaube mein Herz ich hoffe
unglaubliche ausgleichheit
die Reportage zeigt mir microso sind
wieder die Schweiz vielleicht nicht so
gezielt das Hirndoping gesetzt wie im
Silicon
oder das munter machen
Potenzial voll lsdner Dosen auf
und falls ihr die Reportage gefallen hat
dann lade ich ein Like da und abonniert
den Kanal